prime minister is expected to announce
plans to tackle illegal immigration
tomorrow well joining me now is our
correspondent shingi marurike who is in
kigali in rwanda and you're there shingi
because the proposals include plans to
fly asylum seekers to rwanda for what
the government calls processing tell us
more
that's right and a really drastic
proposal is this the government
essentially revamping their immigration
strategy after a record year of migrants
crossing the channel last year and the
prime minister's estimates this evening
are that there could be a thousand
people a day making that journey within
weeks which is why he has just put out a
statement which we can bring to you in
which he says that it is plain that that
uh that will ensure the uk has a
world-leading asylum offer providing
generous protection to those directly
fleeing the worst of humanity by
settling thousands of people every year
through safe and legal routes our
compassion may be infinite but our
capacity to help people is not the
people the british people voted several
times to control our borders not to
close them but to control them so boris
johnson using that language there of
controlling our borders and as part of
that plan we can confirm that priti
patel has landed here in rwanda to sign
a deal which the government are
describing as a migration and economic
development partnership but what that
really means is that people who do come
to the uk
crossing the channel all through illegal
means have the potential to be processed
here in rwanda taking a flight which is
more than 6 000 miles and just as the
news has come in we've had a number of
charities already lining up to criticize
those proposals one charity group called
it cruel and they said that it's also
not cost effective we could be looking
at according to them a bill of around
100 1.4 billion pounds to put this
scheme together but it's not just
charities and human rights groups who
are upset by these proposals we've also
had lots and lots of criticism coming
from across the political divide the
lords have already tabled a number of
amendments to this bill david davis
another senior conservative mp also
questioning whether it is both morally
and legally justifiable so we now know
that migrants will be processed here in
rwanda but that is a set of plans which
is obviously attract a lot of criticism
deeply controversial no doubt shingi
thank you very much indeed